un conflit meurtrier qui pourrait encore
s'éterniser depuis début novembre
des affrontements ont lieu dans le tigré
région dissidente du nord de l'ethiopie
des combats violents entre l'armée
fédérale et les troupes de la région qui
aurait provoqué la mort de plusieurs
centaines de civils un bilan humain qui
inquiète les organisations
internationales dont les nations unies
ont dit que les troupes fédérales
éthiopienne entamé leurs préparatifs
pour encercler mekele amnesty
international rappelle à toutes les
parties qui attaqué délibérément des
civils est interdit par le droit
humanitaire international et constitue
un crime de guerre
les européens ont fait part de leur
préoccupation condamné les violences à
caractère ethnique et demander la
protection des civils l'ultimatum lancé
dimanche dernier par le premier ministre
éthiopien prend fin ce mercredi
il exhorte les dirigeants de la région
du tigré à déposer les armes
un ultimatum assortie d'une menace
d'assaut final al'approche de la
bataille de mekele capitale de cette
région dissidente la route vers votre
destruction touche à sa fin et nous vous
demandons de vous rendre dans les
prochaines 72 heures
vous êtes un point de non retour
saisissez cette dernière chance alors
que l'union africaine tente une
médiation
le sujet divise à l'échelle
internationale ce mardi le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu a dans un premier
temps été annulée à la demande des pays
africains des discussions se sont tout
de même tenu sans aboutir à une position
commune depuis le début des combats
pas moins de quarante mille habitants du
tigre et se sont réfugiés au soudan ou
dans d'autres régions de l'ethiopie